hey guys welcome back to the oven and
katelynn podcast so Kayla yes I have an
assumption that I want to make what is
it I assume that our audience might want
another assumptions about us podcast are
you zooming that because we were only
able to get to a fraction of the
assumptions in the last one yes yeah a
lot to go I think today's assumptions
about us is gonna be all about our
relationship because guys you had a lot
of assumptions about our relationship
again there one I really haven't read
through almost any of these Kaitlin has
organized them and categorize them I'll
be presenting them to you today
I'm so excited I'm so excited let's just
jump into it because there's a lot to
get to there's a lot okay so the first
one and there was conflicting
assumptions about this
the category is fights / disagreements
so on one end of it we have an
assumption from Nicole rich I assume you
guys never fight but if so what about
another we have an assumption from mark
who says well do you or do you want to
do just the first one I assume you guys
never fight if so what about I don't
really think that we've ever fought
because to me like fighting in a
relationship means that we are upset at
each other and I've never really been
upset with you I've been upset in
general about the situation or the
circumstances we found ourselves in but
we've always firmly been on things like
the same team 100% and the main things
we've gotten upset about honestly are
filming under time pressure or
disagreements or miscommunications like
you know time pressures like the thing
that allows us to get stressed and upset
like if there's no time pressure we had
almost never get upset if there's time
pressure and like one of us has assumed
that the other one of us is ready for
this thing
we're filming it and we get out there
and it's not ready and we don't know
what we're doing and we like the cameras
running and like we can't say words and
we get frustrated I think that's the
main thing that we've gotten frustrated
about like yeah but like you said it's
it's it's mostly us being frustrated
like a situation and so we're just kind
of like frustrated in general because of
the situation and that's not to say we
don't have disagreements but I think one
thing that like has been something we
did even before we were dating really is
like we're both kind of over
communicators with each other like
honestly even before we were dating we
were like like I would go to you for
advice on things and you would come to
me for advice on things and we would
just like talk a lot yeah um and I think
that helped a ton plus from the
beginning I mean I think we told the
story sometime in the past but before we
started dating we talked about
everything shared all of our like not
that we have too many secrets or
anything but like we like fully opened
about about up about everything and also
both of us have a strong tendency to
want to like continually advance
ourselves and advance our communication
and advance our skills and everything
like that so I mean before we started
working together I don't think we had
any disagreements at all not really I
mean there just wasn't we live pretty
stress-free lives yeah I mean what there
was stress from like work - especially
towards the end yeah but I was like
you're just directed outwards yeah it
was directed outwards and I know that
like some people are like oh my gosh why
would you like work together wouldn't
that like ruin your relationship and I
think it's just strengthened it you know
the first few times where we had
miscommunications about expectations or
stuff like that right okay how can we
improve our communication so that
doesn't happen again and then we
implemented that and that
miscommunication really hasn't happened
ever again and we I can't really think
of any time in the past year we've
really been where we've like ran into a
situation that upset us
where we had to like sit down and figure
out like why we became upset yeah so the
assumption that you guys never fight if
so what about Nicole you assumed correct
and the only thing that we like that
causes us to really get upset is working
under time pressure because that's like
the most stressful thing especially for
people like us yeah cuz we like take our
commitments very seriously we want to
like deliver deliver and like have good
like you know relationships with our
sponsors and people we make commitments
you know with our schedule and stuff
yeah so so so a related one that's even
more extreme from Mark I assume that at
some point your relationship was almost
over but you stuck together for the sake
of the channel from mark why would you
assume that think of us the reason why
we started this channel was to spend
more time together it's not like oh we
started working together and then as a
result of working together we like got
sick of each other or something like we
the whole reason we started the channel
was to work together so yeah I don't
really first see that ever being an
issue which so interesting because like
assume that your relationship was almost
awful but you stuck together for the
sake of the channel also like the
channel would be terrible if we were
trying to fake relationships or like a
happy relationship actually landfill we
started this and I don't really know why
we assumed that we could make this work
but like for how long did we like
struggle and bust our booties with no
profit no return no like nothing for the
first year or so we got like very little
back yeah in terms of like monetary
compensation
just because we're just going on faith
that like we can make it work we were we
were working like three jobs like
Caitlyn was working a job I was working
a job and we're working this new job
that we are making we are like working
harder than we ever had before for not
much reward at all for a long time and
if you can't do that work for the right
reasons then yeah it might not be good
in the long term but since we knew why
we are doing it from the beginning which
i think is very important because
starting a YouTube channel isn't easy
yes sometimes it is sometimes you just
put a video out there and it goes viral
but the chances of that are almost like
winning the lottery yeah maybe not that
extreme but maybe that extreme yeah yeah
I think that the channel exists because
of our desire to hang out together and
like because of our relationship yeah
not the other way around also like the
videos would be terrible baking also I
think that you guys might know by now
we're not good actors now we the
emotions and everything that you see on
camera that's just us and like in our
lives dreams that's our sauce and us
right here I mean we didn't I did no
prep for this podcast and this is okay
there's just us so it's like you guys
are gonna know if something's off
because we either won't be making
content because that'd be really hard to
do or you'll see us well so related clip
hero assumes that we sometimes have to
edit out fights again they're still in
the fight category assumes that we have
to edit fights out of our video thinking
once every two weeks huh yeah we only
make a video once everybody I think the
main thing we added out are us being
weird well I would say we also added out
boring parts Oh boring parts yeah boring
parts I think there's a lot of boring
that gets cut for sure yeah we've also
gotten better about just knowing what
parts will be boring so we don't know
they're filming it I'm like sanding
that's why it's always montage I will
say there have been a couple times where
it wasn't a fight that we edited out
there's been a couple times especially
when we were under a lot of pressure
where like something went wrong and like
usually when something goes wrong we'll
capture it in the moment like with those
raw emotions
there's been once or twice you remember
the rainbow bench the rainbow bench I
was so upset upset at Kalin but I just
like you know since we had got waiting
yeah I was like Kalin I just need some
time out here in the garage to like
focus on this like I can't talk right
now because I'm just gonna be upset and
I don't want to be upset towards any
people and you're the one around so I
just need to be out here and just see if
I can fix this and I need to be alone
with my feelings yeah and then like once
you add some time then we like did you
know as we do we did show like what went
wrong with like yeah that's being the
wrong way no it's having to just shove a
buttload of of like putty in there to
fill the joints I think that there's
other scenes who are like we're talking
we're talking and then like especially
if it's a long scene that we're filming
just like rest our faces and like get
into like it's like you know we're not
this this is like you know you guys
usually see us in like higher energy
states when we're excited about things
because we're you know the recording
this podcast is exciting it's a fun
thing playing games that's exciting it's
a fun thing and like we're doing
woodworking and crazy tensegrities
Able's and the crazy things that we're
doing it's fun it's exciting so UCS at
all the most excited moments but
honestly a lot of the day is us just
like being normal people in our faces
like answering emails and stuff or like
we get tired - we get tired a lot or
like sometimes all have a headache
I probably get more headaches than
Kaitlyn and sometimes like in between
takes I'll just like rest or something
like that
so we'll cut some of that out - that's
because it doesn't make for a good video
but sometimes we'll leave that in
because it the contrast is funny and
interesting yeah okay sorry I went off
on a kind of a tan man there are of
course we don't really need to respond
to these because we've already kind of
like said how we communicate and stuff
but there were of course positive
assumptions another relationship -
people just didn't assume we were
fighting there's a lot more positive
ones I
think the like fights would be more
interesting to talk about because it's
not just fun when you're just like your
assumption is right and then you move on
but we did get from from Kimi I think
you guys have a really supportive
marriage that's my assumption and Zumaya
I think you guys are I think you're the
best of friends are probably the easiest
relationship because you communicate
well with each other so I'm glad that
that you guys also think that because I
we we think that too we're biased but
yeah so one funny you are my best friend
you are my best man baby i love you i
was like okay so here's a funny funny
thing that we got a couple assumptions
about i categorize this togetherness
because i didn't know what to call it
from Nomura's life i assume you're one
of those we couples that barely ever
does anything separate iiie or EG evan
meeting friends alone etc and sometimes
it drags your friends crazy on a related
one from lorenzo i assume you guys do
capital everything together
i don't like it when like we just spend
long periods of time apart it's like i
like it's just more fun to be together
yeah i don't know maybe we are annoying
to other people but in our defense we
don't have that many friends you know
before we kind of fell into the the full
youtube rabbit hole though - i mean you
you hung out with my friends and like
you got along with all of my friends
super great and i feel like i got along
with your friends really well too so
like we because we are very similar
people if someone liked me they would
probably like Kaitlyn and kind of the
same way around so we bring the same
type of energy to the group dynamic and
everything so with our friends there is
never really a need to choose between
like friends versus significant other
yeah and like when when my friends like
when I invite my friends over and we
wanted to like play video games and
stuff Kaitlyn would like be playing
video games with us cuz like like we she
just fits in with my
dynamic and everything and when odd hang
out with Caitlin's friends like would
all just do things together I mean heck
when Kailen was living in San Antonio
and I lived in Houston I'll Drive every
weekend to spend time with her and one
of the I'm just gonna bring up one
example in particular because it's funny
I'm not gonna talk about all the
drinking times but like the wedding
thing that we went to oh yeah what was
that wedding action it was a wedding
expo because my best friend had just
gotten engaged yeah
Saul was in town and I wanted some time
with Kaitlyn and she just brought me
along and I was just like the like
honorary everyone thought we were the
couple getting married yeah cuz it was
like my best friend one of our other
friends and my best friend's future
mother-in-law yeah
and that's and it's the kind of thing
that you would think like oh you don't
invite like the guys to go so far it's
really final spots when we got our idea
for our marquee love letters I'm gonna
mark your love letters I know it's fun
hanging out with everyone and like we
have little snacks and stuff it was
great snacks so so yeah we do we might
be I hope we weren't too annoying to our
friends to our friends who may be
listening out there you know that about
us so you you already accepted that so
I'm gonna go through some assumptions
about like things that are different
between us yes from intent to modulate I
assume Evans the one who says hey let's
go out and do blank activity outside
their normal routine I think that's
mostly cracked I would say sodium is so
many like over our head situations by
just saying yes or just like just going
for things I was like I I kind of pushed
us through the gaming channel I just
felt like could be I just had this like
gut constant and everything I pushed us
to speak at conferences and everything I
I do kind of push us outside of our
comfort zone a little bit
but Kaitlyn ensures that we actually
like do well at all the things that we
do
I'll just be like chaotically like
leaving things behind and creating them
like like to the next the next thing and
everything like that we balance each
other out very very well I would say
we're in the middle of one of those new
situations that I was hesitant about and
heaven was like let's do it we can do it
I can make that that everything is like
going okay I'm glad that we did it but
there are definitely times where like
yeah we should have done no we can't say
too much you guys will know soon though
yeah okay mmm here's another another one
from Cole my assumption is that Evan is
the impulse is the impulsive one and
Caitlin has to reel him in because she's
pretty grounded I would say you're not
super impulsive I'm not super impulsive
I am flighty with my thoughts I'll say
that's all just like Kalin will
sometimes like you know like we'll both
be at our desks and we'll both be like
working on like you know Caitlin will be
working on the edit and I'll be working
on like a design or the next product or
something and then I'll just be like
browsing random thing isn't everything
like that or I'll just be like sitting
there like staring off into space never
know like check-ins I do have to ground
you in that way so what are you doing
and I'm like oh I have this crazy idea
for this weird project or something like
that and and everything so it's like
when when I bring up new subjects it
might seem like it's coming out of
nowhere oftentimes like the first time I
brought up the gaming channel you're
probably like what or when you when I
brought up we need a second gaming
editor or a third game my fourth gaming
editor you know okay looks like that
seems random like like this is this
coming out of nowhere but oftentimes all
I've been thinking about these stops for
a long time just in the background here
and there and little snippets of thought
so it's like in a way might seem like
I'm impulsive but I'm just flighty with
my thoughts and I cycle lots and lots
and lots of thoughts around and then
I'll bring up something that seems crazy
but I've actually thought
a lot that's the most thing related to
your your but you'd be round me at I'm
related to your ever cycling thoughts
one of my fun games I like to play is
when Evan has that Spacey look I'll be
like what you thinking about and he's
like oh I'm just thinking about the
modularity of this and that and how you
know if we're gonna do a new desk what
if we did this
it's always something just like very
specific and unexpected and usually
related to technology or making and the
latest one was like I'm just thinking
about the power loss of USB cables and
how like the longer the USB cable is
like if it's a high power device at the
end of that it might be like not not
being as efficient and that's why I
think that we might be having problems
with our streaming setup and yet it you
got to be like prepared when you ask
Evan what's on his mind
no sure yeah yeah you better be prepared
to follow along a lot okay um here's a
fun one from G honest I assume that you
are always throwing cheesy compliments
at each other and then cringe because
the cheesy no no we embrace we love the
cheese we and then we dish out that
she's generous oh yes we do yeah so that
is a half correct assumptions yeah okay
here's some this is kind of related to
relationships it's kind of like some
home life type stuff mmm mmm from Tom I
assume that you're absolutely fine with
using the toilet while the other person
brushes their teeth
we usually aren't in the same room but
sometimes if we're carrying a lot of
conversation we'll like talk through a
door or something like that yeah you
know yeah we usually won't be in the
same room sometimes jewbilee open the
door on her and in one of our restrooms
you can't reach the door so the other
one will have to come like close the
door for the other person we're pretty
comfortable comfortable okay then think
you'll be talking about the thousands of
people hey
and I'm the one that compiled this list
okay I assume that you this is from
Goldade I assume that you were always
eating organic food like homemade quiche
and stuff anyone who's tuned into our
gaming chains know that like sometimes
if it's like 8:30 at night and you're
hungry and you're starving and you just
need to eat right now well just gonna
talk about or something yeah get some
drive-thru and we generally like eating
healthy but at the same time we like
healthy alrighty
we love variety we love having like you
know junk food every now and then in
like some salads and then some delicious
home-cooked whatever and just balancing
everything and we'll see you like it's
in K so for a whole meal sometimes
sometimes we'll just have like ramen you
know sometimes you need some ramen and
it's just like this simple thing is that
you want so yeah we do like cook not as
much as we used to but we cook a decent
amount we would like to cook more just
cooking takes a long time it takes a
long time yeah but I think that uh in
general we like every single type of
food the main food that I don't like too
much is you don't like seafood
I don't like seafood and I still don't
fully like wheat things or brown rice
and stuff like that yet the healthier
carbs I just love you like some wheat
bread I do like some a related as a I
from Alexandria I assume that the two of
you make dinner together every night and
it's mostly always the same sort of food
so we kind of just talked about how we
like we're really spoiled with variety
so like we won't like the most will eat
the same thing over Anna meal or in a
week is twice like we might make it once
and then make it again but we are we get
bored really really fast
we're so because we can
cook well and we can we configure meals
work from home so like like lunch today
it was like roasted red potatoes and
roasted green beans and sauteed chicken
with an apricot fresh thyme balsamic
glaze vulgar it was like kind of a fancy
meal but we're like so good oh we have
the we have the stuff to make this and
yeah it's 11:00 in the morning be able
to start our day and I mean we also live
in in Houston which is one of the most
diverse food places I've ever been
I've been to so many places around the
world and Houston has one of the densest
food clusters of variety
yeah I've ever been in that I've ever
been surrounded in so yeah we're spoiled
in that regards too and in terms of
cooking together we we very rarely cook
together this kind of goes back to the
togetherness thing I will say like Wow
we do divide and conquer so sometimes if
it's like the food is rushed neither of
us have like a high priority to do and
we just want to eat soon like one of
like if one of us will leave the primary
cook and one of us will be the sous
chefs like chopping and dicing and
cleaning up dishes but that's more rare
most of the time it just ends up being
one of us has a primary to do like if
the the Edit is in a rush then all do
all the cooking cleaning house and
everything like that if if not like
sometimes Caitlin would rather be the
one to do some of that because she edits
so much she's at her computer so much
yeah I get less rings she can't like you
know we just try to balance everything
who's at the computer more who's
standing more because I'm an entire
priority yeah oh yeah sometimes you'll
be in the garage like sanding for hours
and you want to sit and I've been
editing for hours and I want to stand
yeah so we strive for balance and all of
the things cuz just do one thing all the
time isn't the most fun yeah okay from
Jeremy I think Evan has relinquished all
attic related activities to Caitlin it's
kind of true in a way it's kind of - I'm
just a big clumsy man I still don't know
where my
bizarre like like literally when I was
when I was going through a growth spurt
um you know you you you generally know
where your limits are and everything
like that but my body was growing so
fast for a long period of my life I have
been kind of clumsy because like
literally I think that my arms would be
shorter than the heart of my back you
know so I think that that that's my
excuse of why I'm so a little bit clumsy
yeah and it might be a little
traumatized for the Fall I don't mind
going into the Attic oh here's one um
from tiny Tina Caitlyn is more serious
about financials I will say our
financial responsibilities we kind of
divide and conquer where we're more
serious about financials in different
ways each of us has our area which were
more serious like I'm I take care of
more the like you know weekly accounting
and like quarterly tax stuff evan takes
care of like the investment and
retirement side of things like the big
picture stuff and i'm more of the like
minut stuff yeah like keeping track of
like what types of investments are good
right now
interest rates like figuring out our
long-term savings figuring out our
spending rate figuring out like what
type of retirement we might be able to
figure out as youtubers which is a
strange thing and yeah you know all of
all of that I think of a lot of the
long-term things because that's where my
mind tends to go and kalynn goes toward
the more detailed stuff yes that's what
a little bit more suited for you yeah I
feel good that it suits each of us yeah
okay um we're blasting through these I
feel like we're going through like so
much more like this this round and last
I think we just gotta know we're halfway
through the podcast time flies when
you're answering assumptions hmm okay uh
from you me I assume you guys argue
about who's gonna get up to make coffee
on your days off
we both just want to stay in bed all day
what is this day off you soon laughing
because like going into the 4th of July
weekend sponsors were like hope you guys
have a great holiday weekend hope you
guys get some relaxing in and we're like
as fourth of July weekend what what are
those it's um
today is 4th of July actually and like
we're taking an hour break to have some
socially distanced
hang out next to the pool time with
Evans family for 1 hour and then we are
back and so there's not really days off
I mean you know this is like a subject
that's hard to talk about anytime we
talk about how busy we are because we
are saying yes to all of this fall yeah
we're not like trying to victimizers
opportunities and we really like it
but at the same time you know I think
that we both have realized that this is
an unsustainable pace which is why we've
been trying to reduce things like the
podcast is every other week now the main
channel videos are every other week now
like we have been trying to reduce yeah
and with tensegrities able and this
upcoming project that's like two huge
projects in a row and the amount of time
we've put into both of those projects
has been ridiculous too much
especially too much to do back to back
so what we're still finding the balance
of all these things and you know we
still want to experiment and push even
more in new ways with like second
channel videos and like I want to i
cooking videos more cooking wanna cut
Caleb's hair and not like all of that
stuff but like we need to get our life a
little bit more free and then we're
gonna try attacking all that stuff
playing around with different video
types and everything and just just
having fun and then we'll figure out
once we've experimented with all these
different video types and all of that we
know what all of that is and what the
audience reaction is and how much we
like it all and everything then we'll
feel like we'll be able to better
organize our life and set commitments
and all of that and and and stop working
as much maybe you have some days off
every now and then in terms of coffee
sorry that's long tangent I make the
coffee
really good job at Halon toffee amazing
she makes an amazing cup of coffee and I
appreciate it greatly I am also not a
morning person in any way struggle more
Caitlyn isn't a morning person either
but she's more responsible than I am
also like um jube sleeps on my side and
so like I get the kitty alarm wake up
like and also like I get her breakfast
in the morning when it's so like Jem
starts licking Caitlyn's hair it's like
licking my hair and that's the kitty
alarm she does respectfully wait until
you're like so she waits time stirring
yet it's it's usually like I'm awake
before she starts doing it because she
really likes sleeping - yeah and then
I'll get up I'll get jus but her
breakfast and then I will make the
coffee I wanted some now I wasn't right
now okay from Ryan I assume you all are
night owls and sleep very little I
wouldn't really say that we're night
owls then but we end up being night owls
just because like I'd rather be like
doing stuff and our day than sleeping
cuz sleeping can be a bit boring and I
just love all the things we do in our
day like doing projects is fun like I'd
like to play video games and Kailyn has
been getting into reading again I want
to do like I want to clean the house I
don't organize this I want to do like I
want to rearrange our computer is
another time I want to yeah we
electronic so we kind of resent sleep
but we also are people that require a
lot of sleep and if we if we don't get a
full night it affects us so we actually
try not to sacrifice sleep we just
sacrifice other things instead of sleep
yeah so sometimes we will be working
until midnight but then we'll sleep for
eight or nine hours
our days are shifted yeah to a non usual
hours yeah yeah um okay
here is some more kind of like home life
stuff from it's me Jack I assume that
your house is 100% how you want it
because of all your DIY projects adding
to it
I would say I would say up to a certain
point being a DIY channel and have an
incentive to like tackle projects was
beneficial for our house and past that
it was detrimental to our to our houses
being the way we want it I think the one
thing they're saying is Kaitlyn would
like things to be minimal and we have a
lot of things in our house now I mean
you know the more making the supply as
we get there's just like way more stuff
also we have way more tables than we
need we have so many tables like side
tables coffee tables and benches which
are basically just short tables well
also I think that there's there's
another thing when we first started we
were doing more house projects and we've
done a little bit less just because they
take a long time and there's not as much
of a payout in terms of like well what
you did you you made a floating table
you you you did this crazy thing out of
resin like all of those are so much more
clickable and honestly more fun and like
if we were gonna make our house exactly
how we wanted it we might fix up this
office some more I am you know fix the
doors and like you know make everything
a little why paint the ceiling yeah
paint the ceiling where I fell through
there would be a lot that we would do to
the house but like I think that we're
happy with it in general if we were able
to clean it and organize it I'd like it
yeah it's it's hard to not let the stuff
build up when you're constantly
producing physical things for your
channel yeah right now our living room
is an explosion of all sorts of things
for our the complex project that we're
working on right now it's a complete
chaotic mess there's cardboard boxes
everywhere jube isn't complaining and
it's just because you know I want to
keep the garage clear for other things
and other filming film in there because
we got a film in there but I also have
to lay out all this complex stuff and
figure it out so c'est la vie yep um
from Lauren I assume you all never watch
TV too busy with projects editing
podcast streams we want um YouTube
mostly but we'll mostly do it like if
we're like eating a meal and we want to
walk
something with the meal well we don't do
a ton of watching outside of that like
just for the sake of watching because I
think that sometimes it's you know
before the lockdown and everything and
social distancing or physical distancing
we we used to go out a decent amount and
that like would go out with chat and
would like that'd be like a break
because would be like away from our
house away from projects away from like
we were distanced away from our work far
enough that we couldn't think of
anything there's nothing that we could
do productive so like going out would be
our break and would chat and everything
when we're in and we're surrounded by
all the stuff still I think the best
break we can do is just to like like
hang out and zone out with like a TV
show and everything and that kind of
helps us take a break by like showing us
things to take our minds off of
everything yes and so yeah also
multitasking because we're doing it
while we're eating we're not losing any
productive time and yeah we know that
we're doing good on our schedule when we
like finish the episode that we are
watching instead of pausing at halfway
through that's like how I judge how good
our like how what much can't like how
good we feel where we are with our
projects if we're finishing shows verse
up we've done any time posit we'll
finish it later when we go back to the X
can't finish those last six minutes of
that YouTube well we don't watch TV but
when we were watching Game of Thrones
sometimes a episode of Game of Thrones
would last three meals sometimes two
meals yeah okay here's one from Morgan
Morgan Rose I assume that Evan is a bit
of a neat freak that would prefer
everything have a place I also assume
Caitlin has a secret sword slash knife
collection now not fully switched
Caitlin is more of a neat freak I
actually love organization and Kaitlyn
loves organization too I mean this might
be like a lame Christmas present to
everyone else but those presents I got
Caitlyn once that's a label maker and oh
man that we use that thing so much no
but like we both love labeling things
and organizing things I
I would love to do more Kaitlyn will
will prioritize that more than me
mm-hmm but if I had more time I would
love to do it yeah but Caitlin does put
a higher importance to it and it causes
me more anxiety when things aren't
organized and put away which is why I
think like it it falls higher on my
priority list yeah yeah it doesn't
bother me that much cuz I might add
that's just how it is and we need to
take breaks and there's only so much we
can do I'm more okay like putting it off
but I would say I've gotten better
out of necessity Aylan gotten so much
better serves like so much I can handle
so much more messes I've been a bad
influence cuz you're less stressed about
it I would say I'm less just about it I
just hide the stress away where's that
stress ball okay oh and Evan collects
cool knives I do I love knives
I love utility knives and pen knives and
why you don't have any swords oh man
like I but also like multi tools and
stuff if I had more space and I could
justify getting more I would but I
already have like two normal-sized
Letterman's one or two miniature
Leatherman there's a whole bunch of
knives I'm sad I don't need them anymore
even though I love it um from amin luffy
i feel like you have a live laugh love
singing in your living room at some
point you gotta finish it we've never
had that now Kaylin did do some word art
um that she designed herself and so we
have hung some of that up mm-hmm but no
live laugh love live laugh love yeah we
do have one thing that was a gift that
said like all you need is love and a cat
and that's I think in the guest room
yeah that's like a little like a little
tiny thing that's probably the closest
we have
live laugh love love laugh live yeah
okay um from Samuel I assume that when
people come around your house that have
no idea about your channel they're
confused as to why there's a massive
hamster wheel and a very tiny patio I
think that we might confuse people but
we just haven't had anyone over
everything and so anyone know that when
you come over it knows about our channel
because like if we don't know them well
enough to tell them that about our
channel we certainly don't know them
well enough to like bring them to our
house like all of our friends know about
the channel I think that we have had
like some I remember someone was over at
our house and they're like oh my gosh
like what is all this stuff I don't know
who it was and there was a long time ago
but maybe was like a friend of a friend
or a friend of the family or maybe is
like a more distant relative or
something more distant relative I think
that sounds right yeah yeah but uh
no one's seen the massive hamster wheel
in person because everyone's quarantined
and no one's seen the massive hamster
wheel no one's seen the yeah yeah a lot
of projects mjm CD assumes that we are
huge home bodies with the exception of
Lowe's
you forgot food oh yes we leave the
house most for food yes and then
materials [ __ ] buy materials online
we do very much I mean it's more so now
because everyone honestly I would
actually love to leave the house to go
swimming more like like swim laps that's
one thing that I wish I we had more time
for just because one it'd be good to
work out again so we're gonna try to add
that in I was like one of the next
things we add back into our lives
because yeah that's a good thing to have
in your life we haven't worked on like
three years
yeah but the main outdoor thing I I
think I kind of miss a little bit as
swimming outdoors during the summer I
think it doesn't necessarily have to be
outdoors just not in our house swimming
well if you're gonna no no no I'm saying
like the this assumption Oh
yeah um it's just saying like I assume
that your home buddies but that you can
you can leave your home and not be
outdoors you know what I mean
necessarily it's not only outdoor
activities now we like our house we like
being together we we have a happy life
here and it's like leaving just like I
Drive in waste time doesn't waste time
but like well no I mean we don't we
actually don't mind driving to too much
because we're actually chatting ah yeah
but we are we are a bit homebodies yeah
um from Chris
I assume you're probably fun to hang out
with however your neighbors either think
of you as those weird people next door
or they find you hilarious no middle
ground I think they're probably fun to
hang out with we generally get along
with like all ages of people and but we
don't know our neighbors we don't really
know our neighbors also a lot of our
neighbors have have moved in town and
and we've never gone over to introduce
ourselves to the new ones oh but also
sometimes like I don't know if they're
like leasing or that they live there or
like are they working on the house or
are they moving in or like there's been
a lot of activity around our
neighborhood it's been a lot yeah yeah
but I think that um we actually have
toned down the late-night noises a ton I
mean when we when we first started the
channel all of the work that we did was
late at night and all the fine
woodworking which was extremely loud now
we do so much less woodworking and we
try not to work in the evenings unless
we like try not to work in the shop in
the evenings unless we're on a time
crunch
especially with power tools because you
don't be like it's not baby and
operating a table saw yeah yeah we might
do like some resin stuff or like filmic
quickly yeah after dinner about lower
pressure things yeah hmm from Kathryn I
assume that Caitlin has lots of College
/ adult friends and Evan has more
childhood / high school friends I'd say
we we both have I think you might have
more college friends I think this is
like yeah
pretty right yeah that is true cuz I
don't I don't really keep up with like
childhood high school friends that much
and I have a handful of college friends
that I do still keep up with yeah I
don't know them live you know but most
some are in Houston but like most are
farther away and right now you know
quarantine yeah and I have kept up with
more childhood high school friends than
college friends I think yeah Wow
Katherine how did you know that are you
one of our college or high school
friends um okay there's a lot I'm
reading through the assumptions there's
a lot of assumptions just about how we
don't have much social life we don't
leave the house much we're nerdy home
buddies well but I mean also it's like
if you're doing everything that we do
it's it be hard to leave the house it's
a certain degree yeah I would say to
everyone with those assumptions you
generally right yeah but we're also
pretty cool with it yeah but now we just
like hang out with with people over the
internet like we make new friends like
via twitch and we we play games with
them online and online and Co stream
with them and stuff so that's fun yeah
okay um so I've kind of gone through
some of the ones about like our home
life and our relationship so we can
either move on to thing of the week or I
can just go through some more like
general assumptions about us are we are
we gonna stretch this out and do a third
episode because there's a big
assumptions about work maybe we'll like
could we do that some sense about work
no we have oh we have another huge
category about assumptions about our
work so I think that would be its own
yeah I think let's leave that as its own
we can we can fit in some just
miscellaneous a few more miscellaneous
ones about us there's a huge chunk about
assumptions when we were younger we hit
some of those last time yeah a few more
okay um there's a there's a lot about a
goth or dramatic me makeup person
might be right but there's yeah so um
from scarlet Kaitlyn went through a very
intense emo phase from Jared Kaitlyn was
goth dramatic makeup but then there's
also from Latisse I assume Evan probably
had a goth emo punk scene kid phase so
it's not only directed at me for the
record you were all very cracked I
worked at Hot Topic yeah word - Hot
Topic
I dressed in a very like emo scene thing
that like you went to school like
wearing like oh yeah you know I wore
like knee-high combat boots and like
plaid skirts with chains and like band
t-shirts with skulls on them I had all
the like like bracelets and arm cuffs
like going halfway up my arms I all-out
like the pyramid belts you know -
pyramid belt is where the little spikes
mm-hmm or not spikes like studs yeah um
but sometimes you have to like wear two
because the second one is like for
decoration yeah yeah of course I was
very much not I didn't have any style I
like like I just wore t-shirts and plain
clothes although like I I will say that
you know moving around a lot I went
through a lot of phases most of them
were nerdy like very much similar to
where I am now I did go through one
rebellious phase I did like the sounds
like so cliche but like when I was like
I don't know what's what seventh grade
like 13 13 around 13 I didn't fall in
with like a bad group of people they
weren't the best influence I did some
like not the best things and everything
and yeah I did go through a small
rebellious phase but then I realized
that like why do that that's not nice
and it's not adding anything good to the
world and and all of that and I
reflected on things and and then I was
like I don't want to do that anymore
and when we move like while I was there
I started changing back to a little bit
more where I was for most of my life and
then when we when we moved I just left
all of that behind because there's a
nice opportunity to just like change
things see I moved and I was like I will
become emo now yes it was hard to just
like randomly start dressing you gotta
like it's either a phased approach or
you gotta wait for a move there's a ton
of assumptions is another one that could
be its whole its own whole episode about
like us when we were a younger like and
high school and stuff like that so I'm
gonna move on to some giant high school
that would that would be like a little
like preview if you guys want more
that's one we could do a whole do you
want to do one about work you want to do
what do what about our young younger
selves yeah okay we'll do a couple more
and then we'll move on to thing of the
week um from Grant
I assume that whenever Kaitlyn visits
someone she immediately goes to pay
their cat correct it's like you know me
spot on spot on she's like oh hi person
cat I think like one of the last times
that happened is when we went to visit
Johnny Brook yeah two cats and
immediately sat down and they're like
yes we are now your people - here's him
about you from peach yeah slightly
conflicting from peach I assume Evan
wasn't a cat person at first from small
I assume Evan or I guess he's the same
kind of I assume Evan is a dog person at
heart
cat person dog person I mean we we had a
family dog that I really liked and I've
always liked all animals generally um
I've always thought that they're cute
and everything I think that I I for most
of my life I've also been very self
analyzing and I've always thought about
like who I want to be and what type of
life I want to live and all of that
stuff and I have known that I am very
flighty I'm just a flighty person and I
kind of get in my own head a ton and I
just like out of respect for and the
animals that I would like we bring into
my life I think that I would have
enjoyed a cat or a dog but I never
really would have done it all by myself
because I would have felt bad I think
that's interesting I I just like I just
feel like I wouldn't check in like like
even cats don't need you to check in as
much but I feel like what if I like
forgot like to get out their food or
change their like thing that's like the
animals need attention and love and and
everything and they're not I think dogs
would be more vocal but they also need
so much more yeah you know and also um
moving a ton growing up you know we
moved every single year for a long time
and cat you know cats and dogs weren't
really an option for our family we did
eventually settled down for a while and
get a dog but also like you know I kind
of at some points in my life assumed
that odd I'd be moving to I don't really
know why because when I started working
I didn't move almost at all yeah that's
strange because I had had just the
assumption to cuz both of our parents
moved a lot so it was just like oh well
that's just what you do when you get
jobs sometimes you got to move for the
job so mentally prepared to move every
few years yeah so so I'm not really sure
if your assumptions are right or wrong
because I'm a little bit more IIIi have
always wanted a pet cats and dogs I've
always liked them but I don't know if I
was a dog person or a cat person just
because I never really let myself be
because I worried about taking care of
them it's interesting yeah what are your
assumptions
I assumed what kind of like you said
like well okay I'll backtrack I think
like a cat person dog person like you
can like both animals and you don't have
to necessarily be both or you don't have
to be one or the other
having said that I am someone that fits
like the textbook definition of a cat
person that doesn't mean that I dislike
dogs it just means that I never had a
dog growing
up and I don't know how to take care of
dogs and I feel like a deep connection
with cats um for you I never really I
didn't assume you were a cat person I
hope that you were open to cats since I
had one before we started dating and I
was just like well does your cat a year
later the cat accepted me too yeah but I
also like never really saw you as like a
strong dog person you know you had a dog
and that's not to say that like you
didn't enjoy your dog I know that you
loved your dog he was that he was a good
boy he was the good boy good boy but
like I didn't see you it was like
strongly identifying with being a cat
person or a dog person as part of your
personality whereas like I strongly
identify like part of my who I am as a
person is being a cat person so I think
that's kind of part of it too it's like
part of it's about like what type of
animal you get along with and want to
have it as a pet and part of this like
do you identify as that yeah I think
it's also I think that a lot of it was
just me being very practical about like
the impacts that a cat or dog would have
on my life
and you know like I think that a cat
fits in their life really well right now
but like I just yeah it's it's
interesting because like typically this
is kind of opposite for us because you
were being like very practical and
you're like no no no doesn't make
logical sense to have a pet right now
and I on the other hand tried to do that
I was like oh and I got my first
apartment I was like you know I'm gonna
furnish my apartment and then I'll go
shopping for cats and get a get a cat um
and by shopping for cats I mean go to
like the cat shelter um and so I ordered
a couch I had a bed I ordered a couch
but I didn't have the couch and I was
like close enough I adopted jube and
didn't you get a white couch - yeah I
got a white couch like ah it was
literally the same trip like I I got a
light it was like a tan like a light
light tan
off-white kind of color couch and I
ordered it and you know I had like went
to the place like the furniture store to
get to look at it but then I had to
order online but since I was in a part
of town I normally wasn't I was like and
my mom was there I was like hey there's
some animal shelters over here like we
might not you know I might not get out
to these later on so we should just like
check out the sounds like the same
excuse we used for like ring-shopping
rock well we're at a mall and there's a
ring store right there
then I found Juba so I drew bound you
yep so I had a bed and a couch on order
yeah okay I think last questions before
thing with the week from
Cory I assume that as cold hearted and
aloof jube is she's actually really
cuddly off-camera
buh buh buh she has moments of being
super needy and cuddling so cuddly and
she does she has moments where like she
wants to be in the same room as us and
if we're moving around she's annoyed at
us yeah um and there yeah there's times
were like she just wants to be in my lap
for hours and get snuggles and then like
she sleeps with us so she's very snuggly
then and then there's time when she goes
into the cat dimension and we don't
really know where she is I'm like she on
the catio no she's not like a do she end
up a bed no she's not on the sushi
and she's subtle in her affection and
cuddles and stuff she's all like like
some caps like like your parents cats
like very aggressive with like hi hi
like that mean fat me I'm gonna attack
you with my head constantly and like you
know like all of that stuff home like
like when we when we hop on the couch if
we're watching a movie or a TV show and
the rare occurrences that we do show
like want to cuddle with us then she's a
lap cat lap cat yeah she's very much a
lap cat yeah
yeah but she doesn't like aggressively
require pets but she does want to be
like in your lap or near I'm sure like
give me like love and everything to like
still come up and like had bought my
foot and I'll
her pets and everything well like she's
only affectionate with the two of us and
no one else yet nobody else nobody else
it's like she'll maybe like sniff them
or like tolerate them but she doesn't
love them
yeah she doesn't even really like that
she's like tolerance the best is like
the best is if she will allow you to be
in the same room with her without her
leaving yeah I love acceptance yeah for
like not strangers but like anyone does
anyone that's not us all right time for
thing of the week game of the week
my thing of the week is a new video game
it's not actually new at all it's seven
days to die it came out like in 2013 oh
my gosh a long time ago but but we're
just becoming kind of like aware of how
great it is like it's been on our list
for a while but we started playing it
with our friend Julie and it's been
really fun and I want to play it more
it's a crafting survival horror game and
like it's so fun because you start with
nothing and then you just destroy houses
and like so there's like hidden gems
everywhere it was like you really feel
like you're like raiding houses for
material yeah and like you know you know
there's like all these like treasures
and loops to find and like it's just a
really fun game and there's like every
seven days there's a zombie swarm so the
whole time you're like trying to survive
you also have to like start preparing
for this zombie swarm every every some
days and every seven days it gets harder
oh I believe in towards your horde
nights yes we've done like we've gotten
to like past day 14 and it's just uh
it's just a fun game so that's my thing
of the week yeah related my thing of the
week is Julie one shot girl that's our
friend that we've been playing with her
twitch channel is one shot girl and I
know not everyone who listens to the
podcast is also into the gaming side of
what we do but if you are and you
haven't been to one of the many streams
where we rated Julie definitely check
out her streams she's awesome she's a
good person
just like just like a wholesome good
person good positive vibes the positive
vibes from our two channels like mesh
well
yeah and overlap nicely and everything
that's that's really fun so if you're
into watching streamers play games
and you like our types of streams I
think that you will like Julie's streams
because she's awesome and if you've
listened this far in the podcast thank
you so much yeah we appreciate you guys
spending time with us it's you know I
know that we're doing podcast every two
weeks now but they're really fun part of
our schedule now I mean I think that I
like you know I've gone through waves
with the podcast but I'm really glad
that we like found our rhythm and
feels like the right amount enjoying and
I really been I've really been enjoying
reading your assumptions about us thank
you for sending it in if you sent it in
and I know that we've this is our second
assumptions podcast and maybe we'll take
a but let us know if you want to hear
more specifically if you want to hear
assumptions about when we were younger
like high school in college or if you
want to hear assumptions about our work
and our day-to-day and what it's like
being youtubers yeah so let us know if
you guys want to hear those and we'd
really appreciate it I think it's so
funny that every now and then we like
get decently high in the rankings in
like the iTunes charts cuz I just like
imagine someone finding like evident
podcast what's it about they like
download it and they get confused weird
hairs about if they like cats or not if
you guys have been on our gaming channel
you know that we like pranking people
let's pull like a really big prank you
guys rate our channel like get other
people to raid our channel really highly
like write some nice reviews they make
us happy anyways but let's like get our
podcasts up higher in the charts and
confuse people
guys hope you're having a good day out
there hope you all are same things and I
look forward to seeing you in the next
one
[Music]